we've got more information on Assassin's
Creed Valhalla xbox game pass is hid in
the cloud and apex legends has just
announced a brand new character
i'm persia and you've reached your save
state for thursday april 30th which
means you have one more day to farm
tarantulas because they're going out of
season thanks to a full reveal trailer
and some interviews we have so much more
information on Ubisoft's newest addition
to the Assassin's Creed series
Assassin's Creed Valhalla is set in the
Viking Age and we'll pick up where a
deceased fate of Atlantis DLC left off
you play as a boy who can be a man or a
woman and leave your clan to a better
life to escape the endless wars and
dwindling resources of Norway narrative
director darby McDevitt told GameSpot
that the storytelling will be very
unique for Assassin's Creed fans and
games as a whole as it relies on
structuring story experiences in a way
he hasn't seen before if you're looking
for more details on Assassin's Creed
Valhalla then make sure you stop by
GameSpot comm if you're looking for
gameplay however then you're gonna have
to wait a week for insight xbox on May
7th
that's where Ubisoft will be showing it
off inside Xbox will also be previewing
next-gen gameplay from xbox and its
partners that's not all Xbox is throwing
at us as Phil Spencer has announced that
it's cloud game streaming technology
project X cloud is coming to game past
later this year this means you and your
friends can stream and play games
together on your devices without needing
to download your game past games you'll
be able to stream whatever you want to
play on the service which makes it
closer to the Netflix of games idea this
is sure to be a bonus for the 10-million
game past subscribers there are but does
a service like this entice you to join
and what do you think about the rise of
game streaming services and finally apex
legends has announced a new character
she's out for revenge
the latest story trailer legacy of a
thief revealed lobha who you may
remember as the child from the revenant
reveal trailer in which her father was
killed that little girl grew up to
become a thief and it seems her
motivation for joining the apex games is
that she has an excuse to avenge her
father's death by seeking out Revenue
her story along with recent data mines
have suggested her abilities can tell
prissy
kill and steal loot Lobo will likely
join the game with season 5 which is
right around the corner starting May 12
what do you think of a thief's character
in Apex n is that going to be a game
changer happy Friday Eve and thanks for
watching
I'm Persia and you can follow me on
twitter at persia underscore x0 and you
already know keep it locked on GameSpot
for all the news reviews and more see ya
[Music]